What's up everyone? I'm Andrea, your
RealLife English fluency coach and today
we're learning 12 typically British words
with Harry Potter. In case you're new here,
every week we make lessons to help you
learn fast English without getting lost,
without missing the jokes and without subtitles.
In fact Aladin says that since learning with our
channel since March his listening skills have
skyrocketed. So if that sounds good to you don't
forget to hit that subscribe button and the
bell down below so that you don't miss any of
our new lessons. Harry Potter is a great movie
franchise to learn British English with because
it's full of vocabulary that natives use a lot,
including British slang. So without further ado
let's jump straight into today's lesson. So the
first word that we're going to take a look at
is "wicked" and now this doesn't mean evil or
something like a wicked witch, for example. It
actually means a good thing. It's another way
of saying excellent. Now you won't hear this
words used in American English but they will
probably use something like awesome to describe
something that in British English is wicked. I'm
gone by the way from Weasley I'm Harry Potter.
so so it's true I mean do
you really have the the what
wicked eternal glory that is what awaits the
student who wins the Triwizard Tournament but
to do this that student must survive three tasks
three extremely dangerous tasks wicked so the next
typically British word is brilliant and this is
a very very British word you won't hear it used
in American English and what it means is it's
used to describe something that's wonderful or
exciting and in particular when you have some
good news so you mean this map shows everyone
everyone everyone where they are what they're
doing every minute of every day brilliant where'd
you get it nicked it from filches office of course
I didn't mean to blow her up I just lost control
the next word that we're going to learn
is bloody now literally this is used to
describe something that is made of blood or
has blood on it but in Britain is used as a
slang alternative to very and it's used to add
emphasis to what you are saying it can also be
used as an alternative to a particular swear word
that some people might use to add emphasis as well
can you imagine looking on we're
gonna go to space if we were late
that was bloody brilliant thank you for that
assessment mr. Weasley how did you do it
nevermind there's a matter maile your best
friend know though now you know what you
know bloody world war now in Harry Potter if
you're a big fan you may have noticed that
they say bloody hell very often in the movie
franchise our next word is Cheers and you may
have heard this when people are making a toast
which usually happens with a glass of wine or
champagne but in Britain we actually use this as
an alternative to thank you our next word is mate
and this is very typically British and is also an
alternative way of saying friend you might have
also heard it in Australian English because
it is also very popular there as well while
they are standing round that monk you're good that
isn't just any man cure but-- mate it's a portkey
oh yes do you get frustrated when trying
to understand fast speaking natives then I
highly recommend our fluent with friends course
in this 40 a week course you will learn with the
first two seasons of friends you'll receive PDF
power lessons every week vocabulary memorization
software access to our fluency circle global
community and so much more and the best part is
you can try it right now for free with our three
part master class all you have to do is click up
here or in the description box below to learn
more and sign up now we hope to see you there
our next word is fancy now you might have heard
in American English the term I have a crush on
someone well in British English we would say
I fancy someone we can also use it to describe
a desire for example I might say I fancy a cup
of tea or I fancy some chocolate don't fancy a
butterbeer no if you think I'm gonna let everyone
risk their lives for me no no this is different
taking that becoming me no well none of us really
fancy you mate yeah imagine if something went
wrong ended up a scrawny specky get forever so our
next word is barking and you'll often find this
word collocated with mad so it becomes barking
mad and this is used to describe someone that's
acting crazy or acting a bit strangely I reckon
you have to be barking mad to put your own name
in a couple in a fire Connolly too long enough now
the next one I really like because it's quite fun
it's quite funny the word is dodging now you would
describe something as dodgy if it's unreliable or
dishonest and we usually use this word when we
want to describe something that is untrustworthy
or that we lack confidence in for example
you might say this car has some dodgy brakes
you're a mess hairy sculpting around Knockturn
alley dodgy place the one known to see you there
people are thinking up to no good the next word is
nutter and it's important to note that you would
probably only use this word with close friends
in a very informal way it's used to describe
someone that's acting crazy or silly or strange
in American English they might say that someone is
nuts for example but in the UK we would say that
someone is acting like a nutter or that person
is a nutter across the ministry still letting you
walk around free Potter you better enjoy it while
you can all right but there's a sell em Azkaban
with your name on it I'll tell you nothing to
stay away from me so our next word is rubbish and
the American English alternative to this is trash
so in America they would call the rubbish bin a
trash can and they might say that they're taking
out the trash whereas we would say I'm taking
out the rubbish however we also use this as a
slang term to describe something that's worthless
untrue or nonsense dear mr. Potter we are pleased
to inform you that you have been accepted at
Hogwarts School of Witchcraft and Wizardry
we thought when we took him in we'd put a stop to
all this rubbish but first you must broaden your
minds first you are interested in learning more
words that are different in British and American
English then I highly recommend that you check
out our podcast where Ethan and I discuss this
and you can learn a lot more vocabulary you'll
find the link in the description box below so
that you can check that out later our next
word is bloke this is a very informal word
it's a slang way of saying man it's creepy shot
was a creepy bloke it's father is a Death Eater
it only makes sense it's one thing for a bloke
to sharpen on it okay it's just so I wouldn't be
going alone because believe it or not someone's
asked me and I said yes she's lying right so
our last typically British word is one of my
favorites because it's a synonym for dessert
and this word is pudding so you will hear this
a lot in the UK as a way of describing pudding
another synonym is also afters so rather than
say I want dessert or we having dessert next
we would say shall we have some pudding
next I think I'll just go have somebody
I hope you enjoyed today's lesson and learning 12
typically British words with me and Harry Potter
thanks for joining me but before I go I highly
recommend that you check out our Harry Potter
playlist where we have lots of great lessons
for you to choose from next take care guys